hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast simplify LC tandem ms
routine workflow complexity for general
use by Joe too slow we're excited to
bring educational web seminar presented
by lab roots and sponsored by thermo
fisher scientific to learn more about
thermo fisher scientific please visit
www tech comm named judy or oracle
blabbers and i'll be your moderator for
today's event before again I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions that you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen or answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you'll be viewing the presentation
in the slide window to enlarge the
window just click on the screen icon
located on the lower right finally if
you have trouble seeing or hearing your
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce Jodie fellow senior scientist
of applications at thermo fisher
scientific please join me in welcoming
joke boo slow I will now turn the
presentation over to thank you Judy
hello this is Joe Debus low from thermo
fisher scientific presenting ways to
simplify routine workflows using liquid
chromatography coupled to ten and mass
spectrometry for general clinical use
this presentation was produced by Jason
live product manager of regulated
products for Thermo Fisher Scientific
chromatography and mass spectrometry
division as you probably know the
interest in clinical LCMS publications
has increased exponentially over the
last few years which means that more and
more clinical laboratories are
considering or are already implementing
lcms systems
for various applications this is because
LCMS technology offers great flexibility
for developing in-house tests to measure
clinically relevant compounds even their
metabolites if necessary with confidence
and small volumes of samples when I say
in-house methods I mean laboratory
developed tests which the US Food and
Drug Administration regulates for in
vitro diagnostic use those who develop
clinical laboratory methods typically
start with peer-reviewed articles to
help them utilize their instruments
reagents and other resources to run
samples and generate data in order to
come up with a reliable procedure to
measure specific things in blood urine
or other biological fluids they must
validate the entire system which
includes the instruments reagents
consumables and standard operating
procedures in order to use the test for
diagnostic purposes let's go over the
things that matter to most the clinical
laboratory operation which are the
quality of the lab developed test
results the efficiency in generating
those results the turnaround time to
report the results and how much it costs
to do all this the total testing process
in clinical laboratories is a patient
focus process every bioanalytical test
has several critical parts that must be
well defined and accomplished in order
to produce a credible final result there
are things that must happen before
samples arrived in the laboratory the
highest percentage of errors occurs
during this time once the laboratory or
once in the laboratory the samples must
be prepared properly the laboratory is
also responsible for properly preparing
reagents and
struments and software to measure what
needs to be measured in each sample the
data that is generated must be carefully
reviewed and reported those who ordered
the tests must not only receive correct
reports they must understand the manner
in which the results are presented in
order to properly interpret an act on
the results the second highest
percentage of errors occurs during this
phase interestingly the processes that
occur in the laboratory account for less
than half of the total errors that can
occur during this whole process each
phase of the process takes time those of
us who work in the laboratory can only
address how quickly an efficiency
efficiently things get done there to
affect the total turnaround time we at
thermo fisher scientific have been
working hard to simplify routine
workflows by developing instruments
software and lab supplies to help you
prepare and analyze as many samples as
efficiently and economically as possible
within the confines of your laboratory
resources we address your concerns for
speed efficiency and laboratory space
restrictions with our compact
multi-channel hplc tanah mass
spectrometry and software that
streamlines workflow we now offer class
one medical devices the prelude md hplc
to perform combined sample clean up with
hplc within two channels that Aleut into
one mass spectrometer then there's the
prelude LX for md hplc which processes
many samples across four channels that
allude into one mass spectrometer the
indoor md triple quadrupole mass
spectrometer and clink wan md software
which can
rolls these instruments processes the
data and reports the results as well so
let's take a look under the hood of the
prelude MD hplc the prelude MD
instrument is intended to separate drugs
or compounds from a sample solution and
introduce these separated drugs or
compounds to a detector and it is for in
vitro diagnostic use that's the intended
use of this instrument the prelude MD
utilizes turbo flow technology for
online sample cleanup which replaces
offline solid phase extraction this is
coupled to hplc or uhplc which separates
compounds of interests and elutes them
to the mass spectrometer doing this
across two channels greatly increases
sample throughput for one laboratory
developed tests or permit you to
simultaneously run two different tests
which utilize the same mass spectrometer
the prelude MD hplc combines sample
cleanup and hplc across two channels in
a compact modular design with easily
accessed columns and solvents you can
run TX methods that utilize turbo flow
online sample cleanup coupled to hplc or
you can run LX methods that inject
samples directly into the hplc column of
either channel by the way whenever I say
hplc columns I mean to include uhplc and
that's thanks to the fact that our
Prelude hplc s can handle pressures
generated by uhplc columns packed with
sub 2 micron particles turbo flow
technology involves patented extraction
columns that rapidly remove a great deal
of unwanted sample
opponents such as proteins salts and
sugars during the sample loading step
proteins are instantaneously excluded
from the pores of the packing material
of the molecules that enter the pores
only those that have an affinity to the
surface chemistry are retain while
others are quickly alluded to waste we
then change the mobile phase to elute
the analytes of interest to the hplc
column any sample components that remain
in the turbo flow column after this
transfer step get washed away while the
analytes of interest undergo a final
separation in the hplc column and
eventually get alluded to the mass
spectrometer whenever we add sample
clean up to an LC separation method the
total run time increases but not the
data window the mass spectrometer sits
there waiting for the next data window
if the data window is half of the total
run time then staggering injections into
two channels will double the sample
throughput and maximize the use of the
mass spectrometer this multi channeling
strategy works with any method that
Aleut the analytes of interest within a
fraction of the total run time and that
includes LX methods that don't utilize
turbo flow sample cleanup cross
sequential operation maximizes the use
of the mass specs time which a
conventional hplc cannot do here is an
example of analyzing urine specimens for
benzodiazepines in one channel of the
prelude MD hplc while the other channel
analyzes the same sample for opiates by
multi channeling across two channels we
are able to analyze to urine specimens
for benzos and opiates in just 13
minutes that amounts to 18 injections
per hour in total and that's 9 benzos
and 9 opiates
the prelude MD hplc allows you to choose
between TX mode which utilizes turbo
flow sample cleanup prior to the final
separation the autosampler injects the
sample and to the loading pumps flow to
the turbo flow column in LX mode the
autosampler injects the sample directly
into the eluting pumps flow of the hplc
column this summary gives you an idea of
how much solvent is used in TX mode
versus LX mode the turbo flow technique
typically uses three solvents from the
loading pumps solvency washes the turbo
flow column so that it can be ready for
the next injection the final separation
of phrase LMK by the attic or column
under control of the eluding pumps
involves a similar amount of solvents as
a researching and chloramphenicol
separation accomplished in LX mode in
either mode the solvent consumption is
low
here are the two LC methods that control
loading and eluding pumps as well as
valves a and B to accomplish TX and LX
separations the blue fields show the
loading pump conditions and the pink
fields show the eluding pump conditions
notice that for LX mode the loading
pumps are set to zero flow the LX mode
does not utilize different valve
positions as does the TX mode which
directs the flows from loading and
eluding pumps to accomplish sample
cleanup transfer of analytes from turbo
flow to analytical columns washing and
aquila breitung the columns also notice
the total run times and data windows of
each method in the alprazolam TX method
we start collecting data 1.6 minutes
after the injection and collect data for
2 minutes in the LX method for recert
being and chloramphenicol we have a one
minute data window that starts 1.4
minutes after the injection other parts
of the prelude MD hplc control include
autosampler parameters temperature
control of the columns and pump restart
settings since the prelude MD hplc uses
positive-displacement pumps rather than
reciprocating pumps as conventional hplc
does there is no flow through the
columns after the completion of the LC
method the pumps quickly refill and just
before the next injection the pumps
pressurized with solvent conditions
specified at the beginning of the LC
method this way we get reproducible
chromatographic peak shapes and
retention times while saving a
tremendous amount of solvents one of the
best features of our software is that it
records pressure traces for each
injection this helps us troubleshoot any
problems with the
pumps columns or plumbing the TX mode
pressure traces show both loading and
eluding profiles for each channel the
pressure cases from both channels are
overlaid at the top notice that both
channels are virtually identical the LX
mode pressure traces are very similar
for both channels this data shows how
reproducible the retention times were
from the turbo flow LCMS method for
alprazolam over 2000 injections during
the course of a hundred hours you can
see a very good reproducibility of
retention times retention times for
researching and chloramphenicol Peaks
from the LX method we're also very
precise since many of our customers have
already invested in automated systems
that do sample cleanup and many have
applications where a simple dilute and
shoot sample preparation is all they
need they still want to multi-channel
their LCMS methods across as many
channels as possible to maximize sample
throughput so we replaced the TX
plumbing with LX plumbing and now have
the prelude LX for md hplc which is
capable of quadrupling sample throughput
the prelude LX for md hplc is intended
to separate drugs or compounds from a
sample solution and introduce these
separated drugs or compounds into a
detector it is for in vitro diagnostic
use the prelude LX for md hplc has four
parallel channels which can run
identical or different methods
simultaneously cross sequential
optimization maximizes the utilization
of the mass spectrometer if all channels
run methods that have a total run time
of four minutes
and data windows less than one minute
then a throughput of almost 60
injections per hour can be achieved in
other words the prelude LX for md hplc
staggers injections across all four
channels almost every minute under these
conditions the prelude LX for md hplc
has a footprint similar to that of the
prelude md hplc rather than two channels
that can do either TX or LX modes our LX
for version runs hplc methods on all
four channels each channel can run
identical or different methods that
allude analytes into a common mass
spectrometers eye on the source here we
see what the endure ND mass spectrometer
sees as it keeps up with each channel of
the prelude LX for md hplc running
different methods across all four of its
channels in this case the entire system
achieves a throughput of about twenty
two injections per hour each channel has
its own unique hplc column and mobile
phases as well as unique data
acquisition parameters for the mass spec
however each method must have the same
ion source temperatures so that there is
no delay when switching between channels
the economic advantage of multi-channel
insistence is obvious rather than make a
huge capital investment for for
individual lc-ms systems which take up a
lot of space and resources you can make
a smaller investment for a single
prelude LX for md hplc and endure a md
mass spectrometer this bundle fits in
the space that would take up that would
be taken up by a single lcms system and
uses the electrical connections nitrogen
gas and argon gas of a sing
lcms system yet the prelude LX for Endor
our bundle can handle four times the
workload of a single LCMS system each
channel produces results for individual
analytes as we run four different
methods simultaneously on the prelude LX
for md hplc with endura md mass
spectrometer we typically get
Precision's less than five percent rsd
with these performance tests that you
see here running the same method across
all four channels over a 24-hour period
typically produces data showing that all
four channels are virtually identical
these data also show how the Endora ND
mass spectrometer kept up with the
workload and produce precise data carry
accounts for each analyte that brings us
to an overview of the Andorian d-10 and
mass spectrometer the Endora MD
instrument is intended to identify and
quantify inorganic and organic compounds
in human specimens this is for in vitro
diagnostic use the enduring ND is a
triple quadrupole mass spectrometer
designed to reliably identify and
quantify various analytes from various
samples that have been processed by
various chromatographic and sample
cleanup strategies in order to minimize
sample matrix interferences when coupled
to optimized sample cleanup and
chromatographic processes the indoor md
mass spectrometer provides accurate and
reliable quantitation over a wide range
of sample sizes and concentrations the
advanced design of the indoor MD mass
spectrometer allows fast selected
reaction monitoring or SRM transitions
from precursor to product ions
more about this a little bit later it
can record up to 300 SRM transitions per
second in either positive or negative
ion modes using either heated
electrospray ionization or atmospheric
pressure chemical ionization sources the
indoor md mass spectrometer comes with a
syringe pump to make infusions and a
valve to do flow injection analysis or
divert waste away from the ion source
the curved shape of the high-performance
quadrupole used for the collision cell
between the first and third quadruples
contributes to the compact design of the
Endora MD mass spectrometer the ion
source housing permits us to easily
switch between our heated electrospray
ionization or hesse probe and
atmospheric pressure chemical ionization
or a PCI probe the sensitivity of any
mass spectrometer is a function of how
many analyte ions are formed in the
ionization source and how many of those
ions get introduced into the mass
analyzers while excluding interfering
ions and neutral compounds the RF lens
multipole and neutral beam blocker are
optimized to transmit the ionized
analytes of interest into the mass spec
mass analyzers as efficiently as
possible while preventing interfering
components from entering the first and
third quadruples q1 and q3 of the Endura
MD mass spectrometer are linear the
second quadrupole q2 is curved and is
used to induce collisions of our analyte
ions with argon or nitrogen gas to
produce fragments a typical selected
reaction monitoring event involves
isolating individual analyte ions which
we call precursor ions by q1 according
to their master
charge ratios the precursor ions are
transmitted to q2 where they are
fragmented into product ions q3 then
isolates each population of fragment
ions according to their master charge
ratios and sends them to the detector to
get counted each SRM event occurs very
quickly in the endure MD mass
spectrometer as it can perform up to 300
SRM events per second the mass
calibration of the Endora MD is
accomplished by infusing a calibration
solution of analytes with positive and
negative master charge values that you
see here the control software of the
Endura MD mass spectrometer does the
calibration automatically the hesi probe
is capable of positive ion mode negative
ion mode or foes fast polarity switching
between positive and negative ions these
types of scans are programmed in the
data acquisition portion of the software
electrospray ionization is used most
often for analytes that are thermally
libel and for analyze that are already
ionized the APC I probe is most often
used for analytes that are not already
ionized such as most steroids and those
that can survive high temperature
vaporization without decomposing such as
by dehydration a PCI also operates in
positive and negative ion modes or fast
polarity switching
we call the TX method for alprazolam
that we went over several slides ago you
saw how reproducible the retention times
were across the two channels of the
prelude ND hplc among 2000 index here we
see the precision concentration
measurements made from those injections
an analytical range from 1 to 100
nanograms per ml is shown here as an
example of how calibration curve looks
and one can determine which fit linear
or quadratic and which data waiting such
as one of our X would provide the most
accurate quantitation in order to
qualify a chromatographic peak to be
quantitated we need some assurance that
the peak is pure we typically measure at
least to SRM transitions for each
analyte one for quantitation and one for
confirmation the processing portion of
our software automatically calculates an
eye on ratio of the two transitions for
each alluding analyte here we see the
precision of measuring iron ratios for
the quality control samples among two
thousand injections across across both
channels of the prelude MD hplc many
applications require switching between
positive and negative ion srms we tested
three and door MD mass spectrometers
with hesse probes each connected to a
prelude MD hplc by running the LX method
for researching and chloramphenicol on
each channel of each unit we ran four
batches which specified five replicate
injections of test samples along with
calibrators for recert being we
monitored positive I in transitions that
are shown here
and for chloramphenicol we monitored
negative ion transitions that we see
here the respective calibrators with
internal standards were used to
construct the calibration plus that you
see here and calculate concentrations
and our test samples from 120 replicate
injections of the test samples we
demonstrated reproducible results for
both researching at one and a gram per
ml and chloramphenicol at 1000 grams per
ml after demonstrating reproducible
quantitation of positive and negative
analytes from replicate injections using
the heated electrospray ionization or
hesse probe among three different endura
and D mass spectrometers we switched
ionization sources I mentioned earlier
that atmospheric pressure chemical
ionization or a PCI is most often used
for analytes that are not already
ionized such as many steroids as long as
they are thermally stable at the
temperatures use in the mass
spectrometers ion source using sis
posture own as our test analyte for
positive ion transitions that you see
here and estradiol with negative ion
transitions that you see here we were
able to demonstrate reproducible
quantitation of each in our test samples
testosterone at 39 grams per ml and
estradiol at 60 nanograms per ml showed
our sd's of less than four percent and
less than eight percent respectively the
prelude md hplc and endura md mass
spectrometer are operated using quinn
quan md software version 1.0 the clinic
juan md data processing software is
intended for storing retrieving and
processing laboratory data from the
Endura md mass spectrometer and prelude
md hplc instruments the clinic juan md
software is intended for in vitro
diagnostic use clin quan md software
streamlines the workflows for LCMS
applications and clinical laboratories
it features security functions which
allow lab directors to set permission
levels as required by the clinical
laboratory improvement Amendment or
clear of 1988 clin quan md software
maintains audit trails to simplify
record-keeping and ensure the integrity
of the results clin quan md software
provides default permission settings for
three levels lab directors supervisors
and technicians in order to comply with
clear requirements in addition it
provides flexibility and naming
additional roles and assigning
responsibilities for everyone who will
use the system roles and
responsibilities are defined by the lab
director in the administrative console
portion of the clink wan md software the
lab director also keeps track of audit
trails here is an example of permissions
set for technicians the lab director can
easily permit or prevent access to
various parts of the software for all
users the lab director can also name and
manage custom levels of roles and
responsibilities to accommodate every
user even service engineers from the
technicians point of view clin quan md
software is easy to use the technician
can select predefined batch templates
with
validated methods complete the sample
lists even using a barcode reader and
start running samples all with just a
few mouse clicks the technician can
either select a predefined batch
template that already has a validated
method associated with it or create a
batch from scratch in this case a
validated method is being selected next
the technician builds the work list
either manually with the help of a
barcode reader or by importing a text
file that was created offline the
technician can specify the batch to run
over one or more hplc column hplc
channels as you see here after the batch
is completed and checked the technician
can run the batch the supervisor can log
into clin quan md software to view
chromatograms as they run review
calibration and QC results as soon as
they are available and review test
results for the specimens at the
successful completion of the batch the
supervisor approves the results and
files the bachelor reports clinic wan md
software presents batch results with
status flags to alert the supervisor of
any issues with the final results for
each injection analyte Peaks as well as
their respective internal standard Peaks
must pass specifications for retention
times areas symmetry and ion ratios in
order to assure their identities and
purities calibration plots must pass
specifications for regression statistics
precision and accuracy QC results must
pass specifications for precision and
accuracy these specifications are
defined by the lab director and written
into the
testmethod the supervisor can easily
spot any result that is in question and
repeat injections or determine if any
specimen exceeds the limits of the
calibrators and needs to be diluted
before reinjection once the supervisor
is satisfied with the quality of the
data the batch reports can be generated
and filed from instruments startup to
final reports clin quan md software
streamlines the entire workflow with
flexibility and ease of use in summary
to simplify routine workflows involving
LCMS for general clinical use and
address your concerns for speed
efficiency and laboratory space
restrictions we offer compact
multi-channel hplc tandem mass
spectrometry and software approved as
class one medical devices are our
instruments software and lab supplies
can help you prepare and analyze many
samples as efficiently and economically
as possible on behalf of JSON lie and
our colleagues at thermo fisher
scientific i thank you for your
participation in this webinar Jason and
I will now be glad to answer any
questions you may have about this
presentation
you're nay if you have a question you'd
like to ask Joe please do so now we also
have Jason line for most Scientifics
regulated product manager of el SMS pre
diagnostics and research ivd toxicology
department of chromatography and mass
spectrometry divisions from a call to
answer any technical questions just
click on the green Q&A button the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for okay let's
get started our first question is will
you provide user training online yes the
answer is yes usually when we provide
training they are three parts so first
we'll have the on-site training and our
trainer will be on site to show the user
how to use the instrument and then we'll
have follow-up visits to make sure the
user they can run instrument or they
have any questions and all the training
material and slides will be provided to
the user in addition the online training
module will be provided for the user to
remind them if they need to go impact to
look at some of the modulars overall the
training is a standardized course so we
emphasize on the on-site training in
prelude md can you run one channel with
LX mode any other channel with TX mode
yes that's the beauty of the cradle
empty and it provides flexibility so one
channel you can run LX model and the
other channel you can run
toprol more or equal 11 posts LX mo for
wrong Grampa's cable troll ok can you
run the same sample set with two
different test method yes in one of the
slides of which we show if you use some
example methods for obvious and and in
that the person you can see they all
come in from the same sample and you
could prepare for two spaceman you can
do that 10 mins interact directly with
quinn quan md currently of the first
version there is no direct link but we
can use expo or import the file into the
green one empty and when you mean iron
ratios is it analyte area ratio of both
transitions yes it's all for example if
you look at some of the earlier slides
when they mention the iron ratio it is
the ratio of the confirming I on to the
quantitation lion and they are using the
thick area to get their ratio ok it
looks like we have time for one more
question so it is what are these flow
rates again sorry if I missed that Joe
can you answer that question yeah the
prelude md hplc as well as the LX for
version is capable of going from 10
microliters a minute up to 2 milliliters
per minute
okay I would like to once again thank
you to do solo for his presentation do
you have any final comments you like to
share well I appreciate everyone's
participation in this presentation and
there are additional questions that we
don't have time to answer live but we
will certainly get your contact
information and do our best to answer
your questions offline thank you once
again Joe I would also like to thank our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing for
six months from today's live event which
will be December 30th 2015 you'll
receive an email from lab roots let me
know when this webcast will be available
for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues of may
have missed today's live event that's
all for now thank you for joining us we
hope to see you again soon goodbye